we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
one of the things that bothers me the
most about the ignorance that pervades
our society
is when people call in and they
criticize me for things i haven't set
for points i haven't actually made
criticize me for things i've said and do
it factually and then we'll have a good
conversation the san antonio troll is
someone who makes a habit of this he
calls in all the time and he often will
criticize me for things i didn't say
sometimes it's things maybe from other
shows that he watched and in this case
he criticizes me
for saying
india walton would have won if she had
been more of a socialist i never said
that i'm not a socialist i don't believe
running as more of a socialist would
have helped her but that's still what
i'm getting criticized for take a listen
to this it's sad
uh pac-man you know
i just i'm sorry to call again man you
know who this is it's just you don't
even have to play it i just needed to
get my voice to you i
am
my mind is blown listening to your video
dude like your take was india walton
losing the buffalo mega rice
your take is that
these candidates aren't socialists
enough she lost to a writing candidate
like
and your take is all they need to be
more socialism like bro
i never said that
i never said that
uh i don't even know where he could have
gotten it did someone else say it i
don't really watch other shows like mine
but is there or one of did one of my
colleagues
say that india walton would have won if
she had been more socialist
it's just not my analysis criticize me
for things i've said let's listen to a
little bit more dude it's time to like
just
i get it these opinions like hating the
father
hating the flag hating the family hating
the police
hating capitalism must be taught has to
be talking about some other show right
hating the big corporation i understand
these are very popular opinions on like
twitter reddit
and discord and and youtube even but
look man it just doesn't want elections
dude people are like
hey you know i love my family you know i
don't want to
go talk to someone who's actually making
these claims that would be my advice to
the san antonio troll we've got a great
bonus show for you today there is one
republican senator ready to vote to move
forward with uh debating a major
democratic voting rights bill and that's
lisa murkowski one republican senator
we'll talk about that number two the
american psychological association is
now apologizing for previously
perpetuating systemic racism what did
they do we'll talk about it is their
apology substantial we will talk about
it and lastly
colorado hospitals are now in a position
where they may need to turn patients
away because of a resurgence in covet
cases and they are going to be allowed
to do it we're going to talk about all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show which you can get instant
access to by becoming a member at
joinpackman.com if you'd rather do the
pledge via patreon that will also get
you access to the bonus show you can go
to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
producerpat will join me great bonus
show otherwise we will be back tomorrow
with another show
one of our sponsors is nebia who have
developed the most impressive shower
head i've ever seen it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water and what
they created the nebia bimon spa shower
uses 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head but with an 81
percent more powerful spray and they do
this by using atomized droplets that
rinse soap and shampoo off faster than
any shower head i've ever used i
installed nebia by moan spa shower in my
bathroom at home took five minutes to
set up i've been using it for about a
year
i'm in and out of the shower way faster
because of that powerful spray but again
it's helping the planet and your wallet
by using 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head nebia is
currently offering free shipping in the
us on pre-order products and for all
other nebia products like the shower
head which starts at just 199 you'll get
10 off when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video